l'autre procès en france où l'on reparle
de la sphère du petit grégory à partir
de mercredi en effet jean marie villemin
va se trouver devant les assises il est
accusé de l'assassinât de son cousin
bernard laroche qu'il soupçonnait d'être
l'auteur de l'enlèvement de son fils
grégory une affaire qui remonte déjà à 9
ans mais que la presse n'a jamais cessé
de traiter en long et en large
isabelle stress et dominique verdeilhan
récit neuf ans durant lesquels tout a
été dit vu entendu enregistré
photographier premières photos celles
prises par un photographe de presse
locale le corps de grégory flottant dans
la vologne
nous sommes alors le 16 octobre 84 il
est 21h15 quelques minutes plus tard
l'enfant qui semble dormir et repêché
par un sapeur pompier
l' affaire grégory commence dès le
lendemain la presse affluent la vallée
de la vologne devient soudain le centre
du monde médiatique
les gendarmes sont bavards les
conférences de presse quotidiennes les
journalistes piste les gendarmes qui
pistent l'assassin pas un mouvement des
enquêteurs n'échappe à la presse la
collaboration est étroite
parfois trop les résultats on vous les
donne lorsqu'on les a mais on ne peut
pas être suivi en permanence par cinq
six véhicules
le ton change en revanche lorsque l'anc
et piétine on en sort absolument on en
est exactement au même point qu'à midi
et que hier il ya deux jours
malheureusement si jamais vous pouvez
nous aider
ce sera bien accueilles appel à moitié
entendu oui la presse va participer à l'
enquête jusqu'à créer deux clans les
pros villemin et les pros la roche
non la presse ne va pas prendre ses
distances incompatibilité entre deux
notions le droit et le devoir d'informer
et le secret de l'instruction
l' affaire grégory ou l'instruction à
presse ouverte arrestation et
inculpation de bernard laroche devant
les caméras de télévision
presse tout aussi présente lors des
reconstitutions et des obsèques
photographes et cameramen sont toujours
aux premières loges
la presse se passionne pour l'histoire
extraordinaire de cette famille
ordinaire pendant neuf ans le couple
villemin et traqués jusque dans son
intimité en marge de l'enquète c'est
sous l'oeil de la presse que christine
porte son deuxième enfant au moindre
geste
les caméras tournent les flashs
crépitent comme ici le baiser de
christina jean-marie extrait de prison
le temps d'une reconstitution mère
courage pour les un monstre
d'indifférence pour les autres christine
harceler se cache est un peu et même
beaucoup affolés par les attaques
qu'elle subit non pas de la part des
magistrats mais de la part des gens de
la presse d'au moins de certaines une
certaine presse et en conséquence l art
de la crainte à vous affronter
aucun rapport d'expertisé aucune
audition ne garderons le sceau du secret
la sphère ne quitte pas la une les
photos se vendent à prix d'or souvent
avec l'accord tacite des intéressés
comme ici leur mariage en 88 de
marie-ange laroche parfois au grand dam
des protagonistes comme ici muriel bolle
témoin à charge pour bernard laroche
harceler eux aussi les magistrats et les
avocats
certains cèdent à la pression médiatique
ainsi le juge lambert il n'est pas avare
en confidences et se plaît à commenter
ces décisions de justice
son successeur maurice simon est plus
discret ne parle pas à la presse
du moins dans un premier temps car à son
tour le juge simon finira par confier
son intime conviction au nouveau
détective et à la 5
un seul magistrat reste muet
le juge martin c'est lui qui referme le
dossier public
ainsi durant neuf ans enquêteurs et
journalistes vont former une caravane
aussi devant les errements de l'enquète
la presse va mener à son tour son
instruction réinterrogeant les témoins
réalisant ses propres reconstitution sur
l'emploi du temps de christine ainsi à
dijon nombreux journalistes seront
appelés à la barre pour avoir été les
témoins et les acteurs d'un feuilleton
sans issue